So here's how a lawyer meets with his client when his client is a prisoner at Guantanamo. There's a little hut with a metal table.
这就是关塔那摩的囚犯如何与律师会面。那里有一个带有金属桌子的小棚子。
He's brought out of the box and shackled to an eye bolt in the floor, with his back to the door. He's forbidden to face the natural light.
他被从箱子里带出来，锁在地面上的吊环螺栓上，背对大门。他被禁止面对自然光。
Joe Margulies at the University of Chicago represents a few detainees at Guantanamo. And he says that to understand that thing about the natural light, you have to understand that the detention facilities at Guantanamo were designed to be the perfect interrogation chambers. And so anything the prisoner wants, including sunlight, he's only going to get with the permission of his interrogators as a reward for cooperating. And anything can be used that way.
芝加哥大学的乔·马古利斯代表了关塔那摩的一些被拘留者。他说，要理解关于自然光的那件事，就必须明白关塔那摩的拘留设施被设计成完美的审讯室。所以囚犯想要的任何东西，包括阳光，他只有在审讯人员的允许下，作为配合的奖励才能得到。任何东西都可以以这种方式被利用。
Mail. Another lawyer discovered when he first got there that his client, a middle-aged gentlemen with five children who is a London businessman who was picked up in the Gambia, and he wasn't getting any mail from his family. And he couldn't understand it, because he felt abandoned and alone from his five children.
邮件。另一位律师在刚到达那里时发现，他的当事人是一位中年绅士，有五个孩子，是一名在冈比亚被捕的伦敦商人，他没有收到任何家人的信件。他无法理解这一点，因为他感到被他的五个孩子抛弃并孤立无援。
And the lawyer had the presence of mind to make inquiries to see what was the matter. And discovered that 16 letters were in the military's possession that they had refused to deliver. And when they did finally deliver them, someone had actually taken the time to redact out the words from the children, "we miss you daddy, we love you daddy, we're thinking of you." That is apparently not right because it disrupts the sense of isolation and despair that they are trying to cultivate.
律师有先见之明地进行了调查，想看看是怎么回事。结果发现军方扣押了16封信，他们拒绝递送。当他们最终递送时，有人竟花时间涂掉了孩子们写的话：“爸爸我们想你，爸爸我们爱你，我们在想你。”这显然是不对的，因为它破坏了他们试图营造的孤立和绝望感。
When prisoners feel despair, they'll cooperate, they'll talk, they'll tell us all the dangerous things they know. That's the idea. Let's make them feel hopeless.
当囚犯感到绝望时，他们就会配合，他们会开口，会告诉我们他们所知道的所有危险的事情。这就是用意。让他们感到绝望吧。
Ever since President Bush announced the global war on terror, we've been told this is a different kind of war, with different rules. The battlefield isn't a jungle in Asia, or a beach in France. It's everywhere. Soldiers aren't guys in uniform. They could be anybody.
自从布什总统宣布全球反恐战争以来，我们就被告知这是一场与众不同的战争，有着不同的规则。战场不是亚洲的丛林或法国的海滩。它是无处不在的。士兵们不是穿着制服的人。他们可能是任何人。
And prisoners of war are different, too, so dangerous, we're told, that we keep them in an offshore facility, in as close to total secrecy as possible, to interrogate whenever we want, however long we want, using methods we have never approved for other wars. And one thing that's just weird about Guantanamo is that, in all of these years that it has been going, why haven't we seen more of these guys on radio and TV?
战俘也不同了，我们被告知他们太危险了，以至于我们将他们关押在离岸设施中，尽可能保持完全的机密，以便在我们想要的时候、无论多长时间，使用我们在其他战争中从未批准过的方法进行审讯。关于关塔那摩，有一件很奇怪的事情是，在它运行的这些年里，为什么我们没有在广播和电视上看到更多这样的人？
Over 200 of them have been released, right? At our radio show, we were talking about this this week and we realized that none of us had ever heard or read an interview with any of those guys. And so, today, you're going to hear from two of those Guantanamo detainees who have been released. And I believe you're going to be surprised at what they're like.
他们中已经有200多人被释放了，对吧？在我们的广播节目中，我们这周谈到了这一点，意识到我们中没有人听过或读过对那些人中任何一人的采访。所以今天，你们将听到两位被释放的关塔那摩被拘留者的心声。我相信你们会对他们是什么样的人感到惊讶。
And we're also going to explain, once and for all, how it is that, under these brand-new government rules and procedures in this new war, somebody can be locked away, basically forever, even when the government's own classified files say he is not a threat to America.
我们还要彻底解释一下，在这次新战争的新政府规则和程序下，一个人怎么会被关起来，基本上是永远，即使政府自己的机密文件都说他对美国没有威胁。
Well, it's This American Life from the WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Our guide for all of this is Jack Hitt. A few years ago, he tackled some of these issues for our radio show, and he's spent a few months digging deeper, trying to understand what's happening now. Here he is.
这是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我们所有这些内容的向导是杰克·希特。几年前，他为我们的广播节目处理过一些此类问题，并且花了几个月时间进行深入挖掘，试图了解现在正在发生什么。他来了。
As best as they can tell, Badr Zaman Badr and his brother were imprisoned in Guantanamo for three years for telling a joke. Actually, for telling two jokes. They ran a satire magazine in Pakistan to poke fun at corrupt clerics, sort of the Pashto edition of The Onion .
据他们所知，巴德·扎曼·巴德和他的兄弟在关塔那摩被监禁了三年，原因就是讲了一个笑话。确切地说，是因为讲了两个笑话。他们在巴基斯坦经营着一份讽刺杂志，专门取笑腐蚀的教士，有点像普什图语版的《洋葱报》。
The first joke that got them into trouble is when they published a poem about a politician called, "I Am Glad To Be A Leader." Here's Badr.
让他们惹上麻烦的第一个笑话是，他们发表了一首关于一位政治家的诗，题为“我很高兴成为一名领导人”。巴德在这儿。
Let me translate a few lines for you.
让我为你翻译几句。
Sure.
没问题。
Before I was so thin and weak, and now I have big stomach. Uh, stuff like that. Yeah.
在我之前我是如此瘦弱，而现在我有了一个大肚子。嗯，类似这样的。是的。
So the guy with the big stomach called up Badr and his brother. He threatened them, and, as best as they can tell, told authorities that they were linked to Al Qaeda, which landed them in Guantanamo, and which leads us to the second joke. This one was in an issue of Badr's magazine that came out in the '90s, after our government set a $5 million reward for Osama bin Laden. Badr's magazine issued its own bounty for the capture of an American leader.
于是那个大肚子的家伙召见了巴德和他的兄弟。他威胁了他们，并且据他们所知，告诉当局说他们与基地组织有联系，这把他们送进了关塔那摩，这也引出了第二个笑话。这个笑话出现在90年代出版的一期巴德杂志上，当时我们的政府为奥萨马·本·拉登悬赏500万美元。巴德的杂志也发布了他们自己的悬赏，抓捕一位美国领导人。
President Bill Clinton. Giving the details how to identify, that he has blue eyes and he's clean-shaven. And the most important thing is that a recent scandal is going on between Clinton and Monica Lewinsky. If someone finds that man, he will be awarded 5 million Afghani, Afghan currency, which was equal to $113 at that time. It's impossible to figure out, yeah.
比尔·克林顿总统。提供了如何识别他的细节，他有蓝色的眼睛，而且刮得干干净净。最重要的是克林顿和莫妮卡·莱温斯基之间最近发生的丑闻。如果有人找到那个人，他将获得500万阿富汗尼，那时的阿富汗货币，相当于当时的113美元。这太不可思议了，是的。
In Guantanamo, were you interrogated about your Clinton satire?
在关塔那摩，你是否因为克林顿的讽刺文章而受到审讯？
Exactly. They were serious, if you really want to kill President Clinton? And we said, no, that's not. That was only satire, and only a way of expression. It is allowed. It is protected in your country, in American law.
正是。他们很严肃，如果你真的想杀掉克林顿总统？我们说，不，不是那样的。那只是讽刺，只是一种表达方式。这是被允许的。在你们的国家，在美国法律中，这是受保护的。
How many times were you interrogated, do you think, about the Clinton article?
你认为你被审问了多少次关于克林顿的那篇文章？
Oh, many times, many times. Me and my brother, each one of us, have been interrogated more than a 150 times.
哦，很多次，很多次。我和我兄弟，我们每个人都被审问了超过150次。
So after hearing the punchline explained 150 times, we finally got the joke, and sent Badr and his brother home. It had been three years since the Pakistani army surrounded their house in Peshawar, came into their living room, which is lined with wall-to-wall bookcases, and arrested them. That's Badr's version of why we jailed them. Here's President Bush's.
所以在听了150次笑话的结尾解释后，我们终于听懂了这个笑话，把巴德和他的兄弟送回家了。距离巴基斯坦军队包围他们在白沙瓦的房子，进入他们摆满书架的客厅并将他们逮捕，已经过去了三年。那是巴德认为我们监禁他们的版本。这是布什总统的版本。
These are people that got scooped up off a battlefield attempting to kill US troops. And I want to make sure, before they're released, that they don't come back to kill again.
这些人是在战场上被抓获并试图杀害美军的人。在他们被释放之前，我想确保他们不会回来再次杀人。
The administration has never wavered on this point. Here's Dick Cheney on Guantanamo.
本届政府在这一点上从未动摇过。这是迪克·切尼关于关塔那摩的言论。
The people that are there are people we picked up on the battlefield, primarily in Afghanistan. They're terrorists. They're bomb makers. They're facilitators of terror. They're members of Al Qaeda, the Taliban.
在那里的人是我们从战场上抓获的人，主要是在阿富汗。他们是恐怖分子。他们是炸弹制造者。他们是恐怖活动的推动者。他们是基地组织和塔利班的成员。
We're told over and over that these prisoners are so terrible that we need an offshore facility away from US law to hold them. But then there's Badr. And every day, more stories like his are coming out. And they raise the question, is Guantanamo a camp full of terrorists, or a camp full of mistakes?
我们被反复告知这些囚犯是如此可怕，以至于我们需要一个远离美国法律的离岸设施来关押他们。但后来有了巴德。每天都有更多像他一样的故事传出来。它们提出了一个问题，关塔那摩是一个关满恐怖分子的营地，还是一个关满错误的人的营地？
In a new study from Seton Hall's law school, researchers simply went to the trouble of reading the 517 Guantanamo case files released by the Pentagon. Here is what they found.
在西顿霍尔法学院的一项新研究中，研究人员只是费力地阅读了五角大楼公布的517份关塔那摩案件档案。这就是他们的发现。
Only 5% of our detainees in Guantanamo were scooped up by American troops on the battlefield or anywhere else, 5%. The rest, we never saw them fighting.
我们在关塔那摩的被拘留者中，只有5%是被美军在战场上或任何其他地方抓获的，仅5%。其余的人，我们从没见过他们战斗。
And here's something else. only 8% of the detainees in Guantanamo are classified by the Pentagon as Al Qaeda fighters. In fact, Michael Dunleavy, head of interrogations at Guantanamo, complained in 2002 that he was receiving too many, quote, "Mickey Mouse prisoners."
还有一点。在关塔那摩的被拘留者中，只有8%被五角大楼归类为基地组织战士。事实上，关塔那摩审讯负责人迈克尔·邓利维在2002年抱怨说，他收到的所谓“米老鼠囚犯”太多了。
In 2004, the New York Times did a huge investigation interviewing dozens of high level military intelligence and law enforcement officials in the US, Europe, and the Middle East. There was a surprising consensus that, out of nearly 600 men at Guantanamo, the number who could give us useful information about Al Qaeda was, quote, "only a relative handful." Some put the number at about a dozen, others more than two dozen.
2004年，《纽约时报》进行了一项大规模调查，采访了美国、欧洲和中东数十名高级军事、情报和执法官员。一个令人惊讶的共识是，在关塔那摩近600人中，能够提供关于基地组织有用信息的人数，“只是相对少数”。有些人估计人数在十几人左右，另一些人则说是超过二十多人。
The Seton Hall study might help explain that. It revealed that 86% of the detainees were handed over to us by Pakistan or the Northern Alliance. And some were handed over to us by a new method. Here's Badr.
西顿霍尔的研究可能有助于解释这一点。它显示，86%的被拘留者是由巴基斯坦或北方联盟移交给我们的。有些人是通过一种新方法移交给我们的。巴德在这儿。
Actually, in our interrogation, the American interrogators have been telling us that they have paid a lot of money to those who handed over us to Americans.
事实上，在审讯中，美国审讯人员一直告诉我们，他们已经向那些把我们交给美国人的人支付了大量金钱。
The problem was, we were offering bounties. You know, $5,000 or $10,000. Al Qaeda brought more than Taliban did. And so, OK, fine, here's your money. Take them to Gitmo.
问题是我们提供了赏金。你知道，5000或10000美元。基地组织的人比塔利班的带来的钱多。所以，好吧，没问题，钱给你。把他们带到关塔那摩去。
That's Rear Admiral John Hutson, the Navy's top lawyer. He was the Judge Advocate General until 2000. He says, essentially, we bought Badr, and a whole lot of other prisoners.
那是海军高级律师约翰·哈特少将。他在2000年之前一直是海军总法务官。他说，基本上，我们买了巴德，还有一大堆其他囚犯。
And when you look at the economy in that part of the world, you know, that really is kind of a king's ransom.
当你看看世界那个地区的经济状况时，你知道，这确实是一笔巨大的财富。
We all know this is a new war with new rules. But what were the old rules? Well, one had to do with POWs.
我们都知道这是一场有着新规则的新战争。但旧规则是什么呢？嗯，其中一个与战俘有关。
The military has always known that all kinds of prisoners get picked up in the fog of war. So it was important to get those numbers down to just the real POWs, since troops on the move didn't want to be burdened with looking after lots and lots of captives. This problem had been more or less solved by the old Geneva Conventions, which required a, quote, "competent tribunal."
军方一直都知道，各种各样的囚犯会在战争迷雾中被抓获。因此，将这些人的人数减少到真正的战俘非常重要，因为移动中的部队不想背负照顾大量俘虏的负担。这个问题被旧的《日内瓦公约》或多或少地解决了，公约要求设立一个所谓的“主管法庭”。
It sounds crazy, a kind of impromptu court hearing, right after a battle. But that is exactly what used to happen. And typically, some 75% to 90% of the people scooped up would be sent home. In the Gulf War of 1991, we captured 982 people, released 750 of them right away, and the remainder were POWs. Like in the old war movies, they gave name, rank, and serial number, and they got certain things, everything from a pledge that they wouldn't be tortured, to a promise that they be released once the war ended, and even the right to send letters home.
这听起来很疯狂，一种即兴的法庭听证会，就在战斗结束后。但那正是以前发生的事情。通常，75%到90%被抓获的人会被送回家。在1991年的海湾战争中，我们俘虏了982人，立即释放了750人，其余的是战俘。就像老战争电影里那样，他们报出姓名、军衔和编号，他们得到了一些保障，从承诺不被虐待，到战争结束后被释放的承诺，甚至有向家里寄信的权利。
But this is a new kind of war, after all. And the administration made the argument that the Geneva Conventions apply only when you're fighting another country, a country with a uniformed army, not when you're fighting terrorists.
但毕竟，这是一种新型战争。政府辩称，《日内瓦公约》仅适用于与另一个国家作战时，即拥有正规军队的国家，而不是当你与恐怖分子作战时。
They do not apply where the individuals captured haven't shown that they deserve those protections.
如果被俘人员没有表现出他们理应获得这些保护，那么公约就不适用。
That's Brian Boyle. He was Associate Attorney General for President Bush when these decisions were made.
那是布莱恩·博伊尔。当这些决定做出时，他是布什总统的副司法部长。
They did not legally qualify as Prisoners of War, because they are not fighting in uniform, because they try to blend in with the civilian population, because they try to take cover in civilian areas.
他们在法律上没有资格作为战俘，因为他们不是身穿制服作战，因为他们试图混入平民人口，因为他们试图在平民区寻找掩护。
Hasn't that been a problem for war for most of the 20th century, or at least in the last couple of conflicts we've been in? I mean, is rooting out Al Qaeda any harder, or how is it harder than rooting out Viet Cong in a local village?
这难道不是20世纪大部分时间战争中的一个问题吗，或者至少在我们参与的最后几次冲突中？我的意思是，根除基地组织是否比在当地村庄根除越共更难，或者它是怎么更难的？
I take the point. I guess the point I was making earlier is that I don't think you can conclude, given the nature of the enemy we're facing, that how we treat Al Qaeda operatives that we're able to capture is going to make any difference at all in how they would treat American personnel in their custody, wouldn't make a difference at all.
我明白你的意思。我想我刚才提到的观点是，考虑到我们所面临敌人的本质，我不认为你可以得出结论，说我们对待俘获的基地组织人员的方式会对他们对待手中美国人员的方式产生任何影响，根本不会有任何影响。
You know, that argument can really take you to some dark places, I think.
你知道，我认为那种观点真的会把你带向一些黑暗的地方。
Here's Real Admiral Hutson.
这是约翰·哈特少将。
If we pick and choose, then other countries can pick and choose whether they're going to apply the Geneva Conventions. And you know, that is a slippery slope that Secretary Powell and others did not want us to go down, because they're looking over the horizon. They know that this isn't the last war we're going to fight. It's not even the next-to-last war we're going to fight.
如果我们挑三拣四，那么其他国家也可以在是否适用《日内瓦公约》问题上挑三拣四。你知道，那是一条滑坡，鲍威尔国务卿和其他人不想走那条路，因为他们着眼于未来。他们知道这不是我们要打的最后一场战争。甚至连倒数第二场战争都不是。
This quarrel about the Geneva Conventions continued for three years, and eventually got down to one very practical question. If you're a prisoner, and you're not protected by the Geneva Conventions, and you might be held indefinitely, could you at least make an appeal in a US court? Here's Attorney General Alberto Gonzales.
关于《日内瓦公约》的争论持续了三年，最终归结为一个非常实际的问题。如果你是一名囚犯，并且不受《日内瓦公约》保护，而且可能被无限期拘留，你至少可以在美国法庭上提出上诉吗？这是司法部长阿尔贝托·冈萨雷斯。
We really are, for all intents and purposes, at war. And so you need not provide access to counsel. You need not provide the ability to challenge their detention in a criminal court. It would be like saying that Germans who were captured in World War II would have to be provided lawyers. The truth of the matter is the rules and procedures of our criminal justice system simply do not apply in this case.
不管怎么说，我们确实在战争中。因此，你不需要提供法律咨询。你不需要提供在刑事法庭挑战他们拘留的能力。这就好比说，在二战中被俘的德国人必须配备律师。事实是，我们刑事司法系统的规则和程序根本不适用于这种情况。
And he's absolutely right, about the Germans, except the Germans were covered by the Geneva Conventions. Finally, in 2004, the United States Supreme Court stepped in. It said, if prisoners aren't going to be covered by the Geneva Conventions, that's fine, but they couldn't be permitted to fall into a legal black hole, not protected by any law at all. They had to be given some way to challenge their detainment. It's one of the oldest rights in Western Civilization, known as habeas corpus.
他是完全正确的，关于德国人，只是德国人受到《日内瓦公约》的保护。最终，在2004年，美国最高法院介入了。它说，如果囚犯不受《日内瓦公约》保护，那没问题，但不能允许他们落入一个法律黑洞，不受任何法律保护。必须给他们某种方式来挑战他们的拘留。这是西方文明中最古老的权利之一，被称为人身保护令。
Habeas corpus, it's a phrase we all know, but, let's be honest, can't ever really remember what it means. It's not a trial, or anything like one. Its more, well, primal. It's a hearing that commands the executive, in this case, the President, to explain why he has jailed somebody.
人身保护令，这是一个我们都知道的短语，但老实说，真的记不住它是什么意思。这不是审判，也不是类似审判的东西。它更像是，嗯，原始。这是一个听证会，命令行政部门，在这种情况下是总统，解释他为什么要监禁某人。
The idea dates back to 1215, England, when the nobles forced King John to sign the Magna Carta and agree to the great writ, later known as habeas corpus. In Latin, it means, show me the body. In other words, a neutral judge got to see the prisoner in person to check if he'd been tortured, and then the judge had the power to require the king to explain, why is this guy jailed. All the executive had to do was answer with a convincing story, and then the guy went back to the dungeon. It's a right so elemental that it's in Article One of the United States Constitution. It's one of the reasons we fought the Revolutionary War.
这个想法可以追溯到1215年的英国，当时贵族们强迫约翰王签署《大宪章》，并同意这份伟大的令状，后来被称为人身保护令。在拉丁语中，它的意思是“出示身体”。换句话说，一位中立的法官可以亲自见到囚犯，检查他是否受到折磨，然后法官有权要求国王解释，为什么这个人被关押。行政部门唯一要做的就是用一个令人信服的故事来回答，然后那个人就回到了地牢。这是一项如此基本的权利，以至于它在美国宪法第一条中。这是我们进行独立战争的原因之一。
And after the Supreme Court granted the detainees access to the courts, right away President Bush started talking like a habeas-loving King John.
在最高法院授予被拘留者进入法庭的权利后，布什总统立即开始谈论起像一个热爱人身保护令的约翰王。
Yeah, look, we are a nation of laws. And to the extent that people say, well, America is no longer a nation of laws, that does hurt our reputation. But I think it's an unfair criticism. As you might remember, our courts have made a ruling. They looked at the jurisdiction, the right of the people in Guantanamo to have habeas review, and so we're now complying with the court's decisions.
是的，听着，我们是一个法治国家。在某种程度上，人们说，嗯，美国不再是一个法治国家，那确实损害了我们的声誉。但我认为这是一个不公平的批评。正如你可能记得的那样，我们的法院做出了裁决。他们审查了管辖权，审查了关塔那摩的人享有人身保护令审查的权利，所以我们现在正在遵守法院的决定。
The administration quickly put together a kind of hearing based in part on the old Geneva Conventions hearing they had abandoned. They called this hearing a Combatant Status Review Tribunal, or in the elegant shorthand of the Pentagon, a CSRT.
政府迅速组织了一种听证会，部分基于他们已经放弃的旧《日内瓦公约》听证会。他们称这次听证会为“战斗人员地位审查法庭”，或者用五角大楼优雅的缩写，CSRT。
These new hearings have one oddity to them. The tribunal assumes all the evidence against the detainee is correct. If the detainee wants to prove them wrong, it will be difficult, because he's not allowed to see the evidence. It's classified.
这些新的听证会有一个奇怪之处。法庭假设对被拘留者的所有证据都是正确的。如果被拘留者想证明他们是错的，那将是非常困难的，因为他不允许看到这些证据。它是机密的。
As a result, these hearings makes strange reading. In many of them, there comes a moment in the dialogue like this one between detainee Abdul Malik and the judging panel.
结果，这些听证会的记录读起来很奇怪。在许多记录中，对话中会出现像被拘留者阿卜杜勒·马利克与评审团之间这样的时刻。
They were each appointed a personal representative who is a military officer, who, in my case, met with my client the day before for 15 minutes, sat silent and failed to present all of the exculpatory evidence in his file, which, of course, any lawyer would have done, not the personal representative.
他们每个人都被指派了一名个人代表，是一名军事官员，在我这个案子里，他前一天和我当事人见了15分钟，保持沉默，未能出示他档案中所有的免罪证据，这当然是任何律师都会做的，而不是个人代表。
And as for confronting the evidence, consider the case of Azmy's client, Murat Kurnaz, a Turkish citizen raised in Germany. The Pentagon accidentally declassified the file, with all the secret evidence against him. And here's what's in it: nothing.
至于对抗证据，考虑一下阿兹米的当事人穆拉特·库尔纳兹的案子，一个在德国长大的土耳其公民。五角大楼意外地解密了他的档案，里面有所有针对他的秘密证据。这是里面的内容：什么都没有。
The classified file contains-- The Washington Post wrote about it-- six statements from military intelligence. That's really what the classified file is. You know, memos saying this person was here, so and so witnessed him. In Kurnaz's case, there are five or six statements saying there's no evidence of any connection to Al Qaeda, the Taliban, or threat to the United States. The Germans have concluded he's got no connection to Al Qaeda, there's no evidence linking him to the Taliban. Over and over and over again.
机密档案包含——《华盛顿邮报》对此进行了报道——六份来自军事情报的陈述。这就是机密档案的内容。你知道，备忘录说这个人曾在某个地方，某某人目击了他。在库尔纳兹的案子里，有五六份陈述说，没有任何证据表明他与基地组织、塔利班有任何联系，或者对美国构成威胁。德国人得出的结论是，他与基地组织没有任何联系，没有证据表明他与塔利班有牵连。一遍又一遍又一遍。
But here's the thing. At the hearing, nobody talks about any of that. His personal representative doesn't bring it up. The tribunal doesn't consider it. And Kurnaz himself doesn't even know about it. He's declared an enemy combatant. He's still at Guantanamo today.
但问题是。在听证会上，没有人谈论这些。他的个人代表没有提出来。法庭没有考虑。库尔纳兹本人甚至都不知道。他被宣布为敌方战斗人员。他今天仍然在关塔那摩。
But wait, there's more. The reason they give for holding him: a friend of his named Selcuk Bilgin blew himself up as a suicide bomber in Turkey in 2003. That's two years after Kurnaz got picked up.
但是等等，还有更多。他们给出的关押他的理由：他的一位名叫塞尔丘克·比尔金的朋友在2003年在土耳其自杀炸弹身亡。那是在库尔纳兹被捕两年后。
So setting aside the sort of remarkable legal proposition that one could be detained indefinitely for what one's friend does, it's factually preposterous. And a simple Google search or call to the Germans would have revealed that his friend is alive and well in Bremen and under no suspicion of any such thing.
所以撇开那个非凡的法律命题，即一个人可以因为朋友所做的事情而被无限期拘留不谈，这在事实上是荒谬的。一个简单的谷歌搜索或给德国人打个电话就会发现，他的朋友活得好好的，在不来梅，没有受到任何此类怀疑。
You heard that right. Kurnaz is in Guantanamo because two years after he got picked up, a guy he knows became a suicide bomber, except that he didn't become a suicide bomber, and is currently living in Germany.
你没听错。库尔纳兹在关塔那摩是因为在他被捕两年后，他认识的一个人成了自杀炸弹手，除了他并没有成为自杀炸弹手，而且目前生活在德国。
Yeah, he's walking around in Germany. I've met him.
是的，他在德国到处走动。我见过他。
Then there's a bunch of Chinese Muslims we accidentally picked up during our sweep in Afghanistan. They are an ethnic minority known as the Uighurs. And they've been battling the communist Chinese since World War II. Conservatives love the Uighurs, which is why they've been passionately defended by the National Review and the Weekly Standard . After a corporate lawyer named Sabin Willett heard about them, he volunteered to represent a Uighur named Adel Abdul al-Hakim and some others. And he flew to Guantanamo to meet them.
还有一群中国穆斯林，我们在阿富汗的清剿行动中意外抓获了他们。他们是一个被称为维吾尔族的少数民族。自二战以来，他们一直在与共产主义中国进行斗争。保守派喜欢维吾尔人，这就是为什么他们一直受到《国家评论》和《每周标准》的热情捍卫。在公司律师萨宾·威利特听说他们的情况后，他自愿为一名维吾尔人阿德尔·阿卜杜勒·哈基姆和一些其他人辩护。他飞到关塔那摩去见他们。
The main thing they wanted to talk about and that was so puzzling to them was that the previous May, the military had told them that they were, in their words, innocent. And why were they still here if they were innocent?
他们最想谈论的事情，也是让他们感到困惑的是，前一年五月，军方告诉他们，用他们的话说，他们是“无辜的”。既然他们是无辜的，为什么他们还在这里？
So wait, what you're saying is, is that Adel and the other Uighurs are, in your opinion, have never been members of any kind of Al Qaeda or jihad, or anything like that.
等等，你是在说，阿德尔和其他维吾尔人，依你之见，从来没有成为任何基地组织或圣战，或类似事情的成员。
Yeah. It's not just my opinion. The defense department has determined that. That means they were never Al Qaeda, never Taliban, never any of that.
是的。这不仅仅是我的观点。国防部已经确定了这一点。这意味着他们从不是基地组织，从不是塔利班，从来都不是任何那些东西。
The government says it would release Adel and the other Uighurs if only it could find a country to send them to. I have an idea. Adel could sail 90 miles north to Miami, where there's an entire city of anti-communists. Or he could be sent to one of the largest Uighur expat communities in Washington, DC. So why aren't we going to be seeing Adel any time soon? Here's Willett.
政府说，只要能找到一个国家把阿德尔和其他维吾尔人送过去，它就会释放他们。我有一个主意。阿德尔可以向北航行90英里去迈阿密，那里有一个完整的反共城市。或者他可以被送到华盛顿特区最大的维吾尔移民社区之一。那么为什么我们很快就不会看到阿德尔呢？威利特在这儿。
I'll tell you what I think the answer is, although no one from the government would admit this. I think the answer is that, if anybody actually met these guys, actually looked at them and took their pictures, and you know had them on TV shows or the radio, they'd be shocked. Because they've been told for four years that the people at Guantanamo are terrorists, and that they're the worst of the worst. And you take a look at Adel, you're going to suddenly realize you've been lied to for a long time.
我来告诉你我认为答案是什么，尽管政府里没有人会承认这一点。我认为答案是，如果有人真的见了这些人，真的看了他们并拍了他们的照片，并且，你知道，让他们上电视节目或广播，他们会感到震惊的。因为四年来他们被告知关塔那摩的人是恐怖分子，他们是恶人中的恶人。当你看看阿德尔，你会突然意识到你被长期欺骗了。
He struck me when I first met him like the kind of kid your college-age son would bring home, you know, his roommate, his buddy from college, home for the weekend. People who meet Adel for the first time, they walk out of the meeting, and their jaw is a little bit unsprung. And they don't say much, because it's hitting them like a ton of bricks. You know, this guy is in Guantanamo?
我第一次见到他时，他给我的印象就像你大学年龄的儿子会带回家的那种孩子，你知道，他的室友，他的大学哥们，周末回家。第一次见到阿德尔的人，他们走出会议时，下巴都有点脱臼了。他们没说什么，因为这对他们来说就像重磅炸弹一样。你知道，这个家伙在关塔那摩？
If Willett is right, this gets to the heart of habeas. The whole point is that the king shouldn't have the right to just detain somebody because it'd be an embarrassment to have the guy free. The Pentagon has an acronym for people like the Uighurs. It's pronounced "enlec." It means No Longer Enemy Combatant. But as Willett notes, it should be Never Was Enemy Combatant.
如果威利特是对的，这就触及了人身保护令的核心。整个要点是，国王不应该有权利仅仅因为让某人自由会令人尴尬就拘留他。五角大楼为像维吾尔人这样的人有一个缩写。发音为“enlec”。意思是“不再是敌方战斗人员”。但正如威利特指出的那样，应该是“从来就不是敌方战斗人员”。
The problem with creating an offshore legal limbo, where there's no habeas proceeding to separate the Al Qaeda fighter from the comedy writer, comes during interrogation. If we've labeled them as terrorists, then that's how they get treated.
创造一个离岸法律边缘地带，在那里没有审判程序来区分基地组织战士和喜剧作家，这带来的问题是在审讯期间。如果我们给他们贴上恐怖分子的标签，那么他们就会得到那样的待遇。
Josh Colangelo-Bryan is a lawyer at Dorsey & Whitney in New York who volunteered at Guantanamo. He represents Juma al-Dossary. For a while, the government thought al-Dossary was a recruiter in America for Al Qaeda, possibly involved in the case known as the Lackawanna Seven. But this is never brought up at his CSRT hearing. Instead, the government simply states that he's Al Qaeda, and as proof lists the various places he's been. Afghanistan, Bosnia, Azerbaijan, the Pakistan border.
乔什·科兰杰洛-布莱恩是纽约多西和惠特尼律师事务所的律师，他在关塔那摩做志愿者。他代表朱马·阿尔-多萨里。有一段时间，政府认为阿尔-多萨里是美国基地组织的招募者，可能涉及被称为“拉克瓦纳七人”的案件。但这在他的CSRT听证会上从未被提及。相反，政府只是简单地声称他是基地组织成员，并作为证据列出了他去过的各种地方。阿富汗、波斯尼亚、阿塞拜疆、巴基斯坦边境。
Supposedly, he was fighting in some of those places, but the government provides no evidence that. They don't quote witnesses. Nobody is on record saying he's Al Qaeda. Here's Colangelo-Bryan.
据称，他在其中一些地方进行战斗，但政府没有提供任何证据。他们不引用证人。没有人记录在案说他是基地组织成员。科兰杰洛-布莱恩在这儿。
What's interesting to me, when we talk about what he was behind in that part of the world, is the allegation that the US military makes against him, that he was, quote, "present at Tora Bora," close quote. The military offers no allegations as to when Juma was supposedly in Tora Bora. It says nothing about what, supposedly, he was doing. Simply that, at some point in history, he was present in that place.
对我来说，当我们谈论他在世界那个地区背后的事情时，有趣的是美国军方对他的指控，即他所谓的“出现在托拉博拉”。军方没有提供关于朱马据称是在什么时候在托拉博拉的指控。关于他据称在做什么，只字未提。仅仅是，在历史上的某个时刻，他出现在那个地方。
Now, Juma says that he's never been to Tora Bora. And again, even if that allegation is true, frankly it doesn't prove anything. Absent some evidence of some involvement in terrorist activity, I simply don't know how you can call someone a terrorist.
现在，朱马说他从来没有去过托拉博拉。再说一次，即使那个指控是真的，坦率地说，它也证明不了什么。没有某种参与恐怖活动的证据，我实在不知道怎么能称某人为恐怖分子。
We tried out many of our new interrogation techniques on Juma al-Dossary. Colangelo-Bryan met with him many times and catalogued what was done with him. Al-Dossary said that Americans forced him to the ground and urinated on him. We put out our cigarettes on him. We shocked him with an electric device. We spat on him. We poured a hot cup of tea on his head. We told him that, quote, "we brought you here to kill you." We beat him until he vomited blood. We threatened to have him raped. We dressed him in shorts and left him in a frigid, air-conditioned room. We abandoned him in another room with no water. We invited him to drink from his toilet bowl, which he did. We wrapped him in an Israeli flag. We told him that we would hold him forever, and we told him that we would send him to Egypt to be tortured.
我们在朱马·阿尔-多萨里身上尝试了我们许多新的审讯技术。科兰杰洛-布莱恩多次与他会面，并记录了对他所做的一切。阿尔-多萨里说，美国人强迫他趴在地上，并向他撒尿。我们把烟头熄灭在他身上。我们用电子装置电击他。我们向他吐口水。我们把一杯热茶泼在他的头上。我们告诉他，所谓“我们带你来这里是为了杀了你”。我们殴打他直到他呕吐鲜血。我们威胁要强奸他。我们让他穿上短裤，把他留在寒冷的空调房间里。我们把他扔在另一个房间里，不给水喝。我们邀请他从马桶里喝水，他确实这么做了。我们用以色列国旗包裹他。我们告诉他，我们将永远关押他，我们告诉他，我们将把他送到埃及接受酷刑。
On a different day, we chained him to the floor, and cut off his clothes while a female MP entered the room. We dripped what we said was menstrual blood on his body. When he spat at us, we smeared this blood on his face. We kissed the cross around our neck and said, "this is a gift from Christ for you Muslims." We videotaped the entire episode.
在另一天，我们将他锁在地板上，并在一名女宪兵进入房间时剪掉了他的衣服。我们在他的身体上滴了我们所说的月经血。当他向我们吐口水时，我们把这种血涂抹在他的脸上。我们亲吻脖子上的十字架说，“这是基督给你们穆斯林的礼物”。我们录下了整个过程。
There's no way to confirm that all this happened to al-Dossary. But other prisoners and officials at Guantanamo have described variations of every technique on the list, including the menstrual blood, the Israeli flag, the references to Christianity, the beatings, the sexual humiliation. Al-Dossary is interrogated still, about once a month. During one visit last winter, he asked Colangelo-Bryan, what can I do to keep myself from going crazy?
没有办法确认这一切发生在阿尔-多萨里身上。但关塔那摩的其他囚犯和官员描述了名单上每种技术的变体，包括月经血、以色列国旗、对基督教的引用、殴打、性羞辱。阿尔-多萨里仍然被审讯，大约每月一次。去年冬天的一次访问期间，他问科兰杰洛-布莱恩，我能做些什么来防止自己发疯？
A few months later during a meeting, al-Dossary asked to go to the bathroom. Colangelo-Bryan and the MP stepped outside the hut and waited. After five minutes Colangelo-Bryan got concerned. He cracked the door open.
几个月后的某次会议上，阿尔-多萨里要求去洗手间。科兰杰洛-布莱恩和宪兵走出了小木屋并等待。五分钟后，科兰杰洛-布莱恩感到担忧。他把门推开了一条缝。
When I opened the door, the first thing I saw was a pool of blood on the floor in front of me. I then looked up and saw a figure hanging. I yelled to the MPs for help. They then began to cut down the noose around Juma's neck.
当我打开门时，我看到的第一件事是地板上的一滩血。然后我抬头看到一个人影悬挂着。我对宪兵大喊寻求帮助。他们随后开始割断朱马脖子上的绞索。
It wasn't al-Dossary's first suicide attempt.
这不是阿尔-多萨里的第一次自杀尝试。
About three weeks later, I was back in Guantanamo. Juma said to me that he didn't want to kill himself without an outside witness. His fear was that if he died and only the military knew, nobody would have known what happened.
大约三周后，我回到关塔那摩。朱马对我说，他不想在没有外部见证的情况下自杀。他的担心是，如果他死了，只有军方知道，没有人会知道发生了什么。
Of course, as we're often told, this war is different. Who wants to be the one that let somebody go who then turns out to be the next 9/11 hijacker? So for the military, there is also this other new thing, a terrifying calculation that there can be no margin of error. Joe Margulies of the University of Chicago represents a few detainees and has been trying to make sense of what's happened at Guantanamo.
当然，正如我们经常被告知的那样，这场战争是不同的。谁想成为那个让某人离开，结果却变成下一个9/11劫机者的人呢？所以对于军方来说，还有这件其他的新事情，一种恐怖的算计，即不能有任何误差空间。芝加哥大学的乔·马古利斯代表了一些被拘留者，并一直在试图弄清楚关塔那摩发生了什么。
If we give them the benefit of the doubt, it is possible-- and there's a lot of evidence to support this-- they had no idea who they were going to be capturing, and they thought they might get more serious people, people who are more seriously involved. The reality is those people never came to Guantanamo. The most serious folks are the ones in CIA custody, of which there are approximately 30, 27, 30, something like that. Those are the people in black sites that we don't even know where they are.
如果我们给他们一点怀疑的好处，这是可能的——而且有很多证据支持这一点——他们根本不知道他们要抓捕的是谁，他们认为他们可能会抓到更严重的人，那些更严重参与其中的人。现实是这些人从来没有到过关塔那摩。最严重的人是那些被中情局拘留的人，大约有30人，27人、30人，大概就是这样。那些人是在我们甚至不知道在哪里的黑色监狱里。
The people of any significance never arrived at Guantanamo. But they didn't know that when the base opened. And they said at the time that these were the worst of the worst. They were trained killers. They would gnaw through hydraulic lines to bring down the plane that was flying them to Guantanamo. I mean, they used the most inflammatory rhetoric.
任何有意义的人从来没有到达关塔那摩。但在基地开放时他们并不知道这一点。他们当时说这些人是恶人中的恶人。他们是训练有素的杀手。他们会咬断液压管路以击落飞往关塔那摩的飞机。我的意思是，他们使用了最具煽动性的言辞。
And it very quickly became apparent that they were just mistaken. And then they were stuck with this PR nightmare. And at the same time, there was this sense, this nagging sense, that, well, maybe they are really bad but we just can't find out. Maybe they're not Afghan dirt farmers, as all appearances seem to be. How do we really know? Maybe we need to use more aggressive techniques to find out. So they kept turning up the heat, and using more and more coercive techniques on people who were less and less significant.
很快就变得很明显，他们只是弄错了。然后他们就被这个公关噩梦缠住了。同时，有一种感觉，这种挥之不去的感觉，嗯，也许他们真的很坏，只是我们找不到。也许他们不是阿富汗农民，尽管所有迹象看起来都是。我们怎么能真正知道呢？也许我们需要使用更激进的技术来找出真相。所以他们不断升温，对那些越来越不重要的人使用越来越多的强制性技术。
In this new war, the plan was to build a prison so bleak that the detainees would give up hope and talk. The military was given a mission, and they did a good job. But many prisoners are now moving into year five. If they're Al Qaeda, detainment is perfectly justified. No one argues that. But think about what these incarcerations are for men wrongfully and indefinitely detained. It's like being buried alive in a coffin.
在这场新战争中，计划是建造一个如此荒凉的监狱，让被拘留者放弃希望并开口说话。军方被赋予了一项任务，他们做得很好。但许多囚犯现在进入了第五个年头。如果他们是基地组织，监禁是完全合理的。没有人会反对这一点。但想想这些监禁对于被错误且无限期拘留的人来说意味着什么。就像被活埋在棺材里一样。
Nobody knows how many of the prisoners are, in fact, the worst of the worst and how many are innocent, but we have a way to find out. It's called habeas corpus.
没有人知道究竟有多少囚犯是真正的恶人中的恶人，又有多少是无辜的，但我们有一种方法可以找出真相。它被称为人身保护令。
Jack Hitt. Coming up, the most popular poem among prisoners at Guantanamo, or if not the most popular, at least it is very, very popular, we're told. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
杰克·希特。接下来，关塔那摩囚犯中最受欢迎的诗，或者如果不是最受欢迎，至少是非常、非常受欢迎的，我们被告知。那是一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Habeas Schmabeas, stories from Guantanamo.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，“人身保护令，算个球”，关于关塔那摩的故事。
So where do things stand now? Well, in 2005, the President signed into law a bill that had solid bipartisan support that would end habeas rights forever for Guantanamo detainees. Whether that law is going to stand and whether detainees are going to get fairer hearings than the military CSRTs is actually still up in the air and is going to be resolved by the courts in the coming months and years.
那么现在情况如何呢？嗯，2005年，总统签署了一项法案，该法案得到了两党的坚定支持，将永远终结关塔那摩被拘留者的人身保护令权利。该法律是否会维持，以及被拘留者是否会得到比军事CSRT更公平的听证会，实际上仍然悬而未决，并将由法院在未来几个月和几年内解决。
This actually brings us to Act Two of our show. Act Two, September 11, 1660.
这实际上把我们带到了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，1660年9月11日。
Habeas rights were originally created in England. And in one of the Supreme Court cases on this issue, 175 members of the British Parliament filed a friend of the court brief, an amicus brief, the first time in Supreme Court history that this has happened. And they argued, first of all, that British citizens being held at Guantanamo deserved better than when they were getting in terms of these rights. And they also said, essentially, are you guys nuts?
人身保护令权利最初是在英国创立的。在关于这个问题的最高法院案件之一中，175名英国议会议员提交了一份法庭之友简报，一份法庭之友陈述书，这是最高法院历史上第一次发生这种情况。他们争辩说，首先，在关塔那摩被扣押的英国公民理应得到比他们现在享有的这些权利更好的对待。他们还说，基本上，你们这些人疯了吗？
This is from their brief, "as members of Parliament of Westminster, amici have a duty to protect human rights and fundamental freedoms against the misuse of public power, the due process of law deeply rooted in Anglo-American legal and political heritage. The exercise of executive power without possibility of judicial review jeopardizes the keystone of our existence as nations, namely the rule of law, as well as the effective protection of human rights.
这是摘自他们的简报，“作为威斯敏斯特的议会议员，法庭之友有义务保护人权和基本自由，使其免受公共权力的滥用，正当法律程序深深植根于英美法律和政治遗产中。在没有司法审查可能性的情况下行使行政权力，危及了我们作为国家存在的基础，即法治，以及对人权的有效保护。
They also pointed out the history of habeas, how, after World War II, Winston Churchill wanted to suspend habeas rights for Nazi leaders and just shoot them. And it was the United States which argued for habeas and for trials, which led to the Nuremberg Trials.
他们还指出了人身保护令的历史，二战后，温斯顿·丘吉尔想暂停纳粹领导人的人身保护令权利，直接枪毙他们。而正是美国人主张人身保护令和审判，这导致了纽伦堡审判。
They also, finally, pointed out how badly it had gone the last time that they, in England, tried to suspend habeas like this in the 1600s, they write. During the British civil war, the British created their own version of Guantanamo Bay and dispatched undesirable prisoners to garrisons off the mainland beyond the reach of habeas corpus relief. The guy who did that was named Lord Clarendon. And in England, one of our regular contributors, Jon Ronson, decided to look into it.
最后，他们还指出，上次他们在英国试图这样暂停人身保护令时，在1600年代，情况有多糟糕，他们写道。在英国内战期间，英国人创建了他们自己版本的关塔那摩湾，并将不受欢迎的囚犯送往大陆以外人身保护令救济范围之外的驻军地。做这件事的人名叫克拉伦登勋爵。在英国，我们的定期撰稿人之一乔恩·容森决定调查一下。
So it turns out that the last person to come up with this exact same way to sidestep habeas corpus is a lord I have never heard of, a not-household-name lord called Clarendon. Who was he?
原来，最后一个提出这种完全相同的方法来绕过人身保护令的人是一个我从未听说过的勋爵，一个不是家喻户晓的勋爵，名叫克拉伦登。他是谁？
I went to a professional, Tony McDonnell, who said he'd take me to Clarendon's grave in Westminster Abbey.
我去找了一位专业人士，托尼·麦克唐奈，他说他会带我去威斯敏斯特教堂克拉伦登的墓地。
Yes, we're here in the south aisle of Westminster Abbey.
是的，我们就在威斯敏斯特教堂的南走廊。
Notice we just passed Charles Darwin's grave.
注意我们刚刚经过了查尔斯·达尔文的墓。
Yes, Charles Darwin is buried here.
是的，查尔斯·达尔文埋葬在这里。
You said you were showing an American party around and somebody spat--
你说你带一个美国团参观，有人吐了——
Spat on it.
吐在他的墓上。
--spat at Charles Darwin's grave.
——吐在了查尔斯·达尔文的墓上。
On Darwin's grave, yes. And wanted to know why he was buried here.
在达尔文的墓上，是的。并且想知道他为什么埋在这里。
And we just passed the spot where Elton John sang "Candle In The Wind" at Princess Diana's funeral.
我们刚刚经过了埃尔顿·约翰在戴安娜王妃葬礼上演唱《风中之烛》的地方。
Yes, that was in front of Lord Stanhope's memorial in the nave.
是的，那是在中殿的斯坦霍普勋爵纪念碑前。
You have to be famous, or a great royalist, or at least someone who worked here, like an organist, to be buried here. Tony is a historian and a blue badge guide, an official Westminster tour guide. He took me down corridors and through chambers until we came to a flagstone on the floor.
你必须出名，或者是一个伟大的保皇派，或者至少是一个在这里工作的人，比如管风琴师，才能埋葬在这里。托尼是一位历史学家和蓝色徽章导游，一位官方威斯敏斯特导游。他带着我穿过走廊和房间，直到我们来到地板上的一块石板前。
Lord Clarendon's grave. He's in vaulted company. Henry V is buried just to his left. And Elizabeth I lies a couple of yards in front of him. Tony explains who Lord Clarendon was.
克拉伦登勋爵的墓。他在拱顶的陪伴下。亨利五世埋在他左侧。伊丽莎白一世躺在他前面几码处。托尼解释了克拉伦登勋爵是谁。
He was, for want a better word, nowadays he'd probably be called the prime minister, and he was the main adviser to the king.
他，用个不那么好的词来说，如今他可能被称为首相，他是国王的主要顾问。
So Clarendon had this job. He was the king's advisor, in the middle of a civil war, in which the king was killed.
所以克拉伦登有这份工作。他是国王的顾问，在一场内战中，国王在内战中被杀。
There were two sides. You've got the Monarchists, and then you've got the Puritans, who murdered the king because they saw the kingdom as debauched and decadent.
有两方。你有保皇派，然后有清教徒，他们谋杀了国王，因为他们认为王国是堕落和腐朽的。
Now, I know you Americans see Puritans as kindly settlers, constantly sitting down to Thanksgiving dinner. We see them as bastards. They were religious fundamentalists. In other words they were--
现在，我知道你们美国人把清教徒看作是善良的定居者，不断地坐下来吃感恩节晚餐。我们把他们看作是混蛋。他们是宗教原教旨主义者。换句话说，他们是——
Men who believed that all they had to do was to overthrow the government, and the reign of Jesus Christ would come once more among them.
相信他们所要做的就是推翻政府，耶稣基督的统治就会再次降临在他们中间的人。
So this was a battle of civilization. It was a battle of religious ideologies.
所以这是一场文明之战。这是一场宗教意识形态之战。
It was most definitely a battle of religious ideology.
这绝对是一场宗教意识形态之战。
So as Puritans, were they seen to be kind of crazy religious fundamentalists.
所以作为清教徒，他们被视为那种疯狂的宗教原教旨主义者吗。
Some of the people were, and they were among the most persecuted after The Restoration.
有些人是，他们是复辟后受迫害最严重的人。
The Restoration, this is when the whole sending people away to offshore islands with dubious sovereignty business took place. It was the period after the war. The Puritans had been defeated. The king, Charles II, was restored to power along with his main adviser, Lord Clarendon.
复辟，这就是整个把人送往具有可疑主权的离岸岛屿的那套生意发生的时候。那是战争之后的时期。清教徒被打败了。国王查理二世与他的主要顾问克拉伦登勋爵一起恢复了权力。
Consider what it was like for Clarendon and the Monarchists. They'd been in exile for years. Many of their friends and supporters had been locked up or killed. The Puritans had been vicious. They had killed the king, and many of the men who had done it were still at large, plotting out there. It was a 9/11-style trauma, and Clarendon behaved in a traumatized way.
考虑一下克拉伦登和保皇派的感受。他们流亡多年。他们的许多朋友和支持者被关押或杀害。清教徒是恶毒的。他们杀死了国王，而许多做过这件事的人仍然逍遥法外，在那里策划着。这是一种9/11式的创伤，而克拉伦登表现得像个受创伤的人。
He probably was paranoid to some extent. The whole of the new establishment were paranoid. They saw plots everywhere. And there was a theme of retribution in the air. Some people say they had good reason to be paranoid.
他可能在某种程度上是偏执的。整个新的建制派都是偏执的。他们到处都能看到阴谋。空气中弥漫着报复的气息。有些人说他们有充分的理由偏执。
Well, these people had done the most unimaginable horrific act. They had killed the king.
嗯，这些人做出了最不可想象的恐怖行为。他们杀死了国王。
They had killed the king. They had views that would have led to anarchy. And they were capable of anything is what would have been said. That's why they were put where they were. And it was for the safety of all of us, and we're doing you all a favor. Heaven knows what would have happened. They were wicked people, and those were the people who were then shipped off by Clarendon.
他们杀死了国王。他们持有会导致无政府状态的观点。而且他们什么都做得出来，这就是人们会说的。这就是为什么他们被放在他们被放在的地方。这是为了我们所有人的安全，我们是在帮你们所有人一个忙。天知道会发生什么。他们是邪恶的人，而那些人就是随后被克拉伦登送走的人。
The exact location of Lord Clarendon's Guantanamo is lost to history. It was probably in Jersey, or Guernsey, which today are rather nice seaside tax havens for the rich. But suspending habeas corpus didn't work out well for Lord Clarendon. He was impeached.
克拉伦登勋爵的关塔那摩的确切位置在历史上已经遗失了。它可能在泽西岛或根西岛，今天它们是相当不错的富人海滨避税天堂。但暂停人身保护令并没有给克拉伦登勋爵带来好结果。他被弹劾了。
At his impeachment trial, he was accused of sending people away to, quote, "remote islands, garrisons, and other places, thereby to prevent them from the benefit of the law, and to produce precedents for the imprisoning of any other of His Majesty's subjects in like manner."
在他的弹劾审判中，他被指控将人们送往所谓“遥远的岛屿、驻军地和其他地方，从而防止他们从法律中获益，并为以同样方式监禁任何其他陛下臣民开创先例”。
And remember, democracy as we know it is still centuries away. Innocent until proven guilty. One man, one vote. Only the most extreme radicals held these views. These were dark times. There were heads on spikes all over London. And still, the people were shocked by Clarendon's disregard for habeas corpus.
记住，我们所知道的民主制度还远在几个世纪之外。无罪推定。一人一票。只有最极端的激进分子持有这些观点。那是黑暗的时代。伦敦到处都是挂在长矛上的头颅。即便如此，人们仍然对克拉伦登无视人身保护令感到震惊。
People took it seriously. And they would have bandied it about with each other, this idea that you had to produce somebody and accuse them in law, in front of their own peers.
人们认真对待它。他们会彼此谈论这个想法，即你必须出示某人并在法律上指控他们，在他们自己的同僚面前。
And the parallels are so obvious when you read the history of habeas corpus and the amount of times it's just been suspended. That is what they all always do. They say that these people are capable of anything. These people do not hold the same values as we do. They're out to destroy our way of life. It's more or less the same situation.
当你阅读人身保护令的历史以及它被暂停的次数时，这种平行关系是非常明显的。这就是他们一直所做的。他们说这些人什么都做得出来。这些人不持有与我们相同的价值观。他们要摧毁我们的生活方式。这差不多是同样的情况。
The one outcome of all of this was the Habeas Corpus Act of 1679, which specifically forbade what Clarendon had done and made it illegal to send a prisoner, quote, "into Scotland, Ireland, Jersey, Guernsey, Tangier, or into parts, garrisons, islands, or places beyond the seas, which are, or at any time hereafter shall be within or without the dominions of His Majesty." And forbade at his remains for 330 years. In England, anyway.
这一切的一个结果是1679年的《人身保护令法》，该法特别禁止了克拉伦登所做的事情，并规定将囚犯送往所谓“苏格兰、爱尔兰、泽西、根西、丹吉尔，或到陛下领土以内或以外的任何海外地区、驻军地、岛屿或地方”是非法的。并且在他死后330年里禁止这样做。至少在英国是这样。
Jon Ronson. He does documentaries for the BBC and is the author of the book, Them .
乔恩·容森。他为英国广播公司制作纪录片，是《他们》一书的作者。
Act Three, We interrogate the Detainees. Yes, the US military had their chance with them. In this act, Jack Hitt talks to two former detainees from Guantanamo. One of these guys, you've heard a little bit from earlier in our show, Badr Zaman Badr, the guy who ran the satirical magazine, in Pashto, with his brother in Pakistan. The other guy was 19 when he was picked up. Abdullah al Noaimi, a kid from well to do family in Bahrain. Here's Jack.
第三幕，我们审讯被拘留者。是的，美国军方有机会审讯他们。在这一幕中，杰克·希特与两位来自关塔那摩的前被拘留者交谈。其中一个人，你们在节目早些时候听到过一点他的心声，巴德·扎曼·巴德，那个在巴基斯坦和他兄弟用普什图语经营讽刺杂志的家伙。另一个人被抓时只有19岁。阿卜杜拉·阿尔·诺艾米，来自巴林富裕家庭的一个孩子。杰克来了。
Abdullah wound up in American custody the way a lot of the men at Guantanamo did. He was a foreigner in Pakistan, and we were offering bounties for guys like that. Remember Murat Kurnaz, the guy whose friend was supposedly a suicide bomber? And Juma al-Dossary? The same thing happened to them.
阿卜杜拉进入美国拘留所的方式和关塔那摩的许多人一样。他在巴基斯坦是一个外国人，而我们为那样的人提供了赏金。还记得穆拉特·库尔纳兹吗，那个朋友据说是自杀炸弹手的家伙？还有朱马·阿尔-多萨里？同样的事情也发生在他们身上。
In Abdullah's case, he was first taken to Kandahar, to a makeshift prison the US set up at an air base with about 20 men to a tent.
在阿卜杜拉的案例中，他首先被带到坎大哈，带到了美国在一个空军基地建立的一个临时监狱，一个帐篷里有大约20人。
When we first go in Kandahar, I was surprised. I had never seen those pictures, or those views, only in ancient movies, like dark ages. We were chained by the legs, like shackled. And they ordered us to pick up rocks. Can you imagine this? They said you should pick up the rocks on the ground, like, put it all together in a pile.
当我们第一次进入坎大哈时，我很惊讶。我从来没有见过那些照片，或那些景象，只在古代电影里，像黑暗时代。我们的腿被锁链锁着，像戴着脚镣。他们命令我们捡石头。你能想象这个吗？他们说你应该把地上的石头捡起来，比如，把它们堆在一起。
There was no water to make ablution or to take a shower.
没有水可以用来洗礼或淋浴。
Badr, the satirist, was taken to that same air base at Kandahar.
讽刺作家巴德被带到了坎大哈的同一个空军基地。
The MPs were treating us very harshly. We had to be on our knees for long hours and to put our hands on our head. And mostly they used the word [BLEEP], and they used to tell us to put our [BLEEP] hand on our [BLEEP] heads. And we didn't like that.
宪兵对我们非常苛刻。我们必须跪在地上很长时间，把手放在头上。他们大多使用那个词[删节]，他们过去常告诉我们把我们的[删节]手放在我们的[删节]头上。我们不喜欢那样。
in the camps, Badr got separated from his brother, the poet. So he devised a way to find him. The detainees didn't have toilets. Instead, they got a bucket, which got filled up with what Badr modestly calls "dirt." Every day, some detainee got chosen to empty the buckets. Badr volunteered.
在营地里，巴德与他的诗人兄弟分开了。所以他设计了一种方法找到他。被拘留者没有厕所。相反，他们得到了一个桶，桶里装满了巴德谦虚地称之为“脏东西”的东西。每天，都有一个被拘留者被选中去清空桶。巴德自愿参加。
Because I wanted to meet my brother, to go from tent to tent. I saw my brother when he was giving me his bucket to empty. That was spring time. He said, "what a spring it is, when there are no flowers, and instead of the smell of the flowers, we have this dirt smell." I can't translate it actually. When it is in Pashto, these are really good beautiful lines.
因为我想见我哥哥，我想从帐篷走到帐篷。当他把桶给我清空时，我见到了我哥哥。那是春天。他说，“当没有花，而且没有花香，取而代之的是这种脏东西味儿时，这是什么样的春天啊。”我其实翻译不出那种感觉。当它在普什图语里时，这些是非常好的美丽的句子。
The sanitary conditions were just as bad, if not worse, for Abdullah. The tent he shared with other detainees was open on all sides and located at the end of the military airstrip. Every takeoff and landing meant a tornado of dirt, the literal kind, blasted through. In the first few days, he heard the other prisoners in the tent talking about their interrogations.
卫生条件对阿卜杜拉来说也同样糟糕，甚至更糟。他与其他被拘留者共用的帐篷四面透风，位于军事简易机场的尽头。每次起降都意味着一场泥土龙卷风，真正的龙卷风，呼啸而过。最初的几天，他在帐篷里听到其他囚犯在谈论他们的审讯。
They told me that they had electric shocks on them. And one of them was threatened to be raped. And they took off his pants. And it was like, I was thinking, well, what am I going to do?
他们告诉我，他们受到了电击。其中一人被威胁要被强奸。他们脱掉了他的裤子。我就在想，嗯，我要做什么？
They took me at night. There was two interrogators. They wanted me to say that I was a terrorist. I told them, "no, I'm not," and everything.
他们晚上带走了我。有两名审讯人员。他们要我承认我是恐怖分子。我告诉他们，“不，我不是，”等等。
Then, they started pushing me and everything. And then they brought a cigarette that the interrogator was smoking. He blew the smoke on my face. Then he came very close, very, very close to my face, and brought the cigarette between my eyes, and he said, "I swear to God, I'm going to put it on your forehead if you don't tell me what I want to hear."
然后，他们开始推搡我什么的。然后他们拿来一根审讯人员正在抽的香烟。他把烟吹在我的脸上。然后他靠得非常近，非常、非常近地贴着我的脸，把香烟放在我的眼睛之间，他说，“我向上帝发誓，如果你不告诉我我想听的，我就把它放在你的额头上。”
I thought about it. I thought that, I felt like this is a jungle, and only the strong lives in it. But still, there is a small creature that can live, but not by facing the lions, or facing big animals. No. But by maybe hiding, or changing their colors as the trees.
我想了想。我想，我感觉这就像一个丛林，只有强者才能活下去。但仍然有一种小生物可以生存，但不是通过面对狮子，或者面对大型动物。不。而是通过也许隐藏，或者像树木一样改变它们的颜色。
So I just told him, "whatever you want to hear from me I'm going to tell you. What do you want me to say?" He says, "say that you are a terrorist."
所以我只是告诉他，“你想听什么我就告诉你什么。你想让我说什么？”他说，“说你是恐怖分子。”
"You want me to say I'm a terrorist? Are you going to let me go? Are you going to let me go to sleep?" Because they always torture, like, not keeping me asleep, by keeping me awake all the time. So, I tell them, "OK, I'm going to tell you whatever you want. Yeah, I'm a terrorist, and go tell your bosses." And they left me.
“你想让我说我是恐怖分子？你会让我走吗？你会让我去睡觉吗？”因为他们总是折磨，比如，不让我睡觉，总是让我保持清醒。所以，我告诉他们，“好吧，我会告诉你们你们想要的任何东西。是的，我是恐怖分子，去告诉你们的老板吧。”然后他们离开了。
This is not how he thought things would go with the Americans. In fact, back when he was being held in a Pakistan jail, when he found out that Americans would be taking them, he was relieved. He told the other prisoners it was good news. He knew America. He knew how the people were.
这不是他认为事情会和美国人进展的方式。事实上，早在巴基斯坦监狱被关押时，当他发现美国人会带走他们时，他感到宽慰。他告诉其他囚犯这是个好消息。他了解美国。他知道那里的人是什么样子的。
I lived so many places like Europe, and England, and Germany, and France. But the difference was that, in the States, everywhere you go they welcome you. Like, when you go in the supermarket, everybody goes, like, how you doing, and everything. That's the thing that was in my mind. I was pleased. Oh, everything's going to be fine. They can understand.
我住在欧洲、英国、德国和法国等许多地方。但区别在于，在美国，你去任何地方，他们都欢迎你。比如，当你进入超市时，每个人都会说，你好吗，等等。那是我脑子里想的东西。我很高兴。哦，一切都会好起来的。他们能理解。
So how did he know so much about American supermarkets? Well, in 1994, he came to America for the World Cup finals. In fact, Abdullah has been here a lot. He's been downhill skiing in the Midwest. He attended Old Dominion University in Virginia for a while, and has taken other trips, too.
那么他怎么知道这么多关于美国超市的事情？嗯，1994年，他为了世界杯决赛来到美国。事实上，阿卜杜拉经常来这里。他在中西部滑过下坡滑雪。他在弗吉尼亚州的老道明大学上过一段时间学，也进行过其他旅行。
And in '96, I was in Disneyland. We were in Orlando. For spring break, I was in Daytona Beach with some of my friends.
96年，我在迪士尼乐园。我们在奥兰多。春假期间，我和我的一些朋友在代托纳海滩。
[LAUGHING] You were in Daytona Beach for spring break?
[笑] 你去代托纳海滩度春假？
Yeah, it was year 2000. Biker's Week. I remember the guys, young guys, standing by that sidewalk, having the signs for the cars passing. Some expression written on it, "show us--"
是的，那是2000年。机车周。我记得那些家伙，年轻人，站在人行道旁边，举着牌子给经过的车看。上面写着某种表情，“给我们看看——”
Show us, oh right. [LAUGHING] Ah, yes. That expression. The show us your--
给我们看看，哦对了。[笑] 啊，是的。那个表情。给我们看看你的——
Yeah, that expression. That's the most I remember about Daytona.
是的，那个表情。那是我对代托纳印象最深的事情。
So a year after seeing the sights at Daytona Beach, Abdullah found himself facing an American interrogator in Kandahar.
所以在他看完代托纳海滩的风景一年后，阿卜杜拉发现自己正在坎大哈面对一名美国审讯官。
I got shocked. I got shocked when the first interview guy kept cursing me, up and down, cursing my father, cursing my family, cursing my country, cursing my government, everything.
我震惊了。当第一个面试的人不停地辱骂我，从头到脚，辱骂我的父亲，辱骂我的家人，辱骂我的国家，辱骂我的政府，辱骂一切时，我震惊了。
Why? That was the question I wanted to know. Like, what was going on? Like, do I know you? What do you have against me? What did I do to you?
为什么？那是我想要知道的问题。比如，到底发生了什么？比如，我认识你吗？你对我有什么不满？我对你做了什么？
Badr had learned of the West from more scholarly sources. He's a big fan of the Canterbury Tales and Gulliver's Travels. And he also knew about the Geneva Conventions, and spoke up when he realised they weren't going to apply.
巴德从更学术的来源了解了西方。他是《坎特伯雷故事集》和《格列佛游记》的忠实粉丝。他也知道《日内瓦公约》，并在意识到公约不适用时大声疾呼。
Actually, our complaint was that they were not accepting us as prisoners of war, they're not giving us those rights. And actually, they were just running away from American legal system.
事实上，我们的抱怨是他们没有接受我们作为战俘，他们没有给我们那些权利。事实上，他们只是在逃避美国法律体系。
I mean, I have told my interrogators many times, if we are really guilty, why won't they put us on trial in American courts?
我的意思是，我多次告诉审讯人员，如果我们真的有罪，为什么不把我们送上美国法庭审判？
Finally Badr and Adbullah were each taken out of the camps at Kandahar and put on a plane to Guantanamo. Remember, this is an international flight from Afghanistan to Cuba, over 20 hours long.
最终，巴德和阿卜杜拉各自被带离坎大哈营地，登上了飞往关塔那摩的飞机。记住，这是一次从阿富汗到古巴的国际航班，飞行时间超过20小时。
We were handcuffed. And the handcuffs were tied to our stomachs. And there's a chain connected to our legs. Other detainees next to you, like, stuck to you.
我们被戴上手铐。手铐被系在我们的肚子上。有一条链子连着我们的腿。旁边的其他被拘留者，就像，粘在你身上。
They used to put goggles on our head.
他们过去常把护目镜戴在我们的头上。
And we had masks, through which we can hardly breath.
我们还戴着口罩，透过它我们几乎无法呼吸。
We could not hear, we could not see. We can even not touch. So they had to stop all senses completely.
我们听不到，看不到。我们甚至无法触摸。所以他们不得不彻底停止所有的感官。
To have hearing, seeing, tasting, smelling, those things only a human can have.
听觉、视觉、味觉、嗅觉，那些东西只有人类才能拥有。
Once they got to Guantanamo, both Badr and Abdullah described being stripped naked, medically examined, and then put into cages until a new round of interrogations began.
一旦他们到达关塔那摩，巴德和阿卜杜拉都描述了被剥光衣服、进行身体检查，然后被关进笼子里，直到新一轮审讯开始。
Mostly they used to ask questions about the relief organizations and how they get money, and why people hate Americans. And so. And there have been even stupid questions.
大多时候他们过去常问关于救济组织的问题，钱是怎么来的，以及为什么人们恨美国人。等等。甚至还有愚蠢的问题。
Like?
比如？
There have been stupid questions that if you have seen Osama bin Laden or Mullah Omar, if you intend to attack Americans?
有一些愚蠢的问题，比如你有没有见过奥萨马·本·拉登或奥马尔毛拉，你是否有意袭击美国人？
As if I know Osama bin Laden. I was like shocked, I'm 19 years old.
好像我认识奥萨马·本·拉登一样。我当时很震惊，我才19岁。
Abdullah and Badr, by the way, arrived at different times at the base and never knew each other. But they both described meeting lots of ordinary people, farmers, teachers, cab drivers, who were also sold to the Americans. Abdullah talked to one guy who has sold by his own father-in-law. Badr met men who had never even heard of Osama bin Laden. After a while, some of them couldn't help but showcase the absurdity of the situation.
顺便说一下，阿卜杜拉和巴德是在不同时间到达基地的，从来不认识对方。但他们都描述了见到许多普通人，农民、老师、出租车司机，他们也被卖给了美国人。阿卜杜拉和一个人交谈，那个人被他自己的岳父卖了。巴德见到了甚至从没听说过奥萨马·本·拉登的人。一段时间后，他们中有些人忍不住展示了这种情况的荒谬性。
Like, for example, one guy, he's a very funny guy, they took him to interrogation. Every day, they took him there for more than 20 hours, keep him awake and have very loud disco music. The lights, like, circling all over his eyes and all over the place. And then, after so many days, under those circumstances, that person just stood up, held the interrogator's hands, and kept dancing with him.
比如，有一个家伙，他是一个非常有趣的人，他们带他去审讯。每天，他们带他去那里超过20个小时，让他保持清醒并放非常响的迪斯科音乐。灯光，像旋转着照在他的眼睛和到处。然后，在那么多天之后，在那种环境下，那个人只是站起来，握住审讯人员的手，不停地和他跳舞。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Yeah, seriously, he kept shaking his body. And the interrogator was going to have a nervous breakdown.
是的，说真的，他不停地摇晃着他的身体。而审讯人员快要神经崩溃了。
Abdullah was originally arrested while traveling in Pakistan. A man offered him a meal and a place to rest and later turned him over to the Army for the bounty. Abdullah says he saw the money change hands at the jail.
阿卜杜拉最初是在前往巴基斯坦旅行时被捕的。一个男人给他提供了一顿饭和一个休息的地方，后来为了赏金把他交给了军队。阿卜杜拉说他看到了钱在监狱里换手。
Once in American custody, he was accused of traveling to Afghanistan and proclaiming his desire to carry out Jihad.
一旦进入美国拘留所，他被指控前往阿富汗并宣称他执行圣战的愿望。
Sometimes, to get to us, or to put the stress on us, they come and ask, like "do you want to go home?" They don't want to take me home, but they are just asking to make you angry and nervous that you'll never go home, and keep telling you those things.
有时，为了触及我们，或者给我们施加压力，他们会过来问，比如“你想回家吗？”他们不想带我回家，但他们只是在问，让你生气和紧张，让你永远回不了家，并一直告诉你那些事情。
But to respond, I tell them the same thing, "No, thanks. I don't want to go home. I'm OK here. I like you so much and I don't want to leave you."
但作为回应，我告诉他们同样的事情，“不，谢谢。我不想回家。我在这里挺好。我非常喜欢你们，不想离开你们。”
[LAUGHING] Now, did they just, did they think you're a smart ass? I mean, how did they react to that?
[笑] 现在，他们觉得你是个聪明人吗？我的意思是，他们对此有什么反应？
They got surprised the first time. But then they got used to it, because everybody was saying it. Even if they, for example, stop you from food, stop you from sleeping, stop you from talking, I don't know why, you just keep smiling.
他们第一次感到惊讶。但后来他们习惯了，因为每个人都这么说。即使他们，例如，不给你食物，不让你睡觉，不让你说话，我不知道为什么，你只是不停地微笑。
So much of what we hear about Guantanamo is about the harsh treatment there, but of course, like any place, the days mostly pass in boredom. The interrogators might be rough, but the MPs and guards who had to spend time with the detainees sometimes would get comfortable and start talking to the prisoners.
我们听到的关于关塔那摩的大部分内容是关于那里的严酷待遇，但当然，像任何地方一样，日子大多是在无聊中度过的。审讯人员可能很粗暴，但不得不花时间与被拘留者在一起的宪兵和守卫有时会变得放松，并开始与囚犯交谈。
They asked me, tell me the truth, are you a terrorist or not?
他们问我，告诉我实话，你是恐怖分子吗？
They were told that I am a terrorist, but they still ask me. Why? Because of doubts in their heart. They still have doubt those people are not, they don't seem like as we've heard. And then we start talking and talking and talking. Most of the guards, they told me that, when I first came here, I was trained that everybody over here is like monsters. They're going to jump from the cages, and they're gonna tear you up and everything.
他们被告知我是恐怖分子，但他们仍然问我。为什么？因为他们心中的疑虑。他们仍然怀疑那些人不是，他们看起来不像我们听到的那样。然后我们开始谈论，谈论，谈论。大多数守卫告诉我，当我第一次来这里时，我受到的训练是这里每个人都像怪物。他们会从笼子里跳出来，撕裂你什么的。
They said, we thought different. We thought that the American forces captured you in a battle or something.
他们说，我们想得不一样。我们以为美国军队在战斗中俘虏了你们。
So some of the people, they are forced to treat us bad. But you can see, you can tell from their eyes. And some, they feel like, this is not the right thing to do. They feel this is wrong. They told me themselves. Some of them told me, like, if I don't follow orders, I'm going to be in your place. I really miss them now.
所以有些人，他们被迫虐待我们。但你可以看到，你可以从他们的眼睛里看出来。有些人，他们觉得，这不是正确的事情。他们觉得这是错的。他们自己告诉我的。有些人告诉我，比如，如果我不服从命令，我就会待在你的位置上。我现在真的很想念他们。
To pass the time, the prisoners would sing together, or try out new poems they'd written. They developed a secret postal system for passing notes and photos, and figured out how to talk to each other through the air conditioning vents. Sometimes, the guards and prisoners would hold little competitions, like the Styrofoam cup challenge. The object was to turn the cup inside out, without cracking it. The guards went first.
为了打发时间，囚犯们会一起唱歌，或者尝试他们写的新诗。他们开发了一个秘密邮政系统来传递纸条和照片，并想出了如何通过空调通风口互相交谈。有时，守卫和囚犯会举行小比赛，比如泡沫杯挑战。目标是在不弄碎它的情况下把杯子翻过来。守卫先来。
They spent hours and hours and hours, and they came back with, uh, they couldn't do it. They said, OK, let's try to flip the cup underwater. They tried and it didn't work. Then the detainees said, OK, we're going to do it for you. The detainees did it. They flipped the cup inside out. Like, totally inside out. You could read the brand of the cup inside the cup instead of outside.
他们花了好几个小时，又好几个小时，他们回来时，嗯，他们做不到。他们说，好吧，让我们试着在水下翻转杯子。他们试了，但没用。然后被拘留者说，好吧，我们要为你们做。被拘留者做到了。他们把杯子翻了过来。比如，完全翻了过来。你可以读到杯子里的品牌，而不是在外面。
What was the brand?
是什么牌子？
It was Dart.
是Dart。
Dart?
Dart？
Yeah, one was Dart, and the other was Oklahoma. Yeah, the community of Oklahoma for blinds.
是的，一个是Dart，另一个是奥克拉荷马。是的，奥克拉荷马盲人社区。
Since pen and paper were forbidden, Badr's brother wrote his poetry by scratching the words into Styrofoam cups with his fingernails. After a year, they were allowed to use pens and to read books. Abdullah read David Copperfield. Badr and his brother composed some 25,000 lines of verse. The other inmates memorized the best of them. The most popular couplet went like this.
由于禁止使用笔和纸，巴德的兄弟用指甲把诗歌刻在泡沫杯上写下来。一年后，他们被允许使用笔并读书。阿卜杜拉读了《大卫·科波菲尔》。巴德和他的兄弟创作了大约25,000行诗。其他囚犯背诵了其中最好的部分。最受欢迎的对联是这样写的。
It says, [PASHTO VERSE]
它说，[普什图语诗句]
These are the Pashto lines. It means "They bring good and bad people to the same jail, and there is no oil or salt in the rice."
这些是普什图语的句子。意思是“他们把好人和坏人带到同一个监狱，米饭里既没有油也没有盐。”
Get that? There's no oil or salt in the rice.
明白了吗？米饭里没有油也没有盐。
It's really funny in Pashto. If you just say this to any Pashto speaker in your country, he would really like that. [REPEATS PASHTO VERSE]
这在普什图语里真的很有趣。如果你把这个说给你们国家的任何普什图语使用者听，他会真的喜欢那个。[重复普什图语诗句]
Finally, one day, four years after he left Pakistan, Abdullah was pulled aside by a military officer who had news. Abdullah was going home. Abdullah says he was asked by a government lawyer, a major, to sign a contract promising not to join a terrorist group and giving the US permission to rearrest him at any time.
最终，有一天，在他离开巴基斯坦四年后，阿卜杜拉被一名有消息的军官带到一旁。阿卜杜拉要回家了。阿卜杜拉说，他被政府律师，一名少校要求签署一份合同，承诺不参加恐怖组织，并允许美国随时重新逮捕他。
He refused to sign. Other detainees say they were shown similar letters and also refused to sign, believing this was just another trick.
他拒绝签字。其他被拘留者说，他们也看到了类似的信件，也拒绝签字，认为这只是另一个诡计。
Did they ever explain why they were letting you go?
他们有没有解释为什么要放你走？
No.
没有。
So, but they told you they had made a mistake in the end.
那么，但他们最终告诉你他们犯了一个错误。
The government lawyer, he didn't say a mistake by the vocabulary of "mistake." He didn't say, "mistake." But he said, "we picked you up as an enemy combatant, but it turned out that you were not one. We don't say that you are an enemy combatant." He gave me an example of a mistake, but he didn't say, "we made a mistake."
政府律师，他没有说“错误”这个词汇的错误。他没有说，“错误”。但他说是，“我们以敌方战斗人员的身份抓了你，但事实证明你不是。我们不说是你是敌方战斗人员。”他给了我一个错误的例子，但他没有说，“我们犯了一个错误。”
And just as suddenly, Abdullah was on an airplane and back in Bahrain. He was quickly ushered past the news media and into a room where he saw his family. They greeted me, they welcomed me, they hugged me and everything. Then they took me home. I didn't tell them anything.
就像这样突然，阿卜杜拉就坐在飞机上回到了巴林。他被迅速带过新闻媒体，进入一个房间，在那里他看到了他的家人。他们迎接我，他们欢迎我，他们拥抱我什么的。然后他们带我回家。我什么都没告诉他们。
Everybody's crying. I left my sister, she was very, very young, about five, six years. I didn't know her when I saw her. She was like a lady.
每个人都在哭。我离开我妹妹时，她非常，非常小，大约五、六岁。我看到她时已经不认识她了。她就像一位女士。
When you saw your brothers and your father, what was that like?
当你看到你的兄弟和父亲时，那是什么感觉？
Have you ever heard the expression "home sweet home"?
你听过“金窝银窝不如自己的狗窝”这个表达吗？
[LAUGHING] Yes, I have actually.
[笑] 是的，我确实听过。
Yeah, of course. That's exactly. That's the best time to say "home sweet home."
是的，当然。就是那样。那是说“金窝银窝不如自己的狗窝”的最佳时机。
Americans are going to think that, because you were at Guantanamo Bay, that you were a terrorist, and that everybody there was. What would you say to them?
美国人会认为，因为你在关塔那摩湾，所以你是恐怖分子，那里每个人都是。你会对他们说什么？
I would say, even if I were an angel, I would still be a terrorist to them, because that is the thing that they want. People don't want to take the responsibilities of their mistakes. And they want to put it on others.
我会说，即使我是天使，对他们来说我仍然是恐怖分子，因为那是他们想要的东西。人们不想承担他们错误的责任。他们想把它推给别人。
It's like slaughtering a sheep, for example. And when the sheep keeps shaking, and the blood's spilling all over the place, they would scream at it, at the sheep, and say, you are a bad sheep, bad sheep, because your blood came on my clothes or my dress. You know what I'm saying?
这就像屠宰一只羊，举个例子。当羊不停地发抖，血溅得到处都是时，他们会对着它尖叫，对着羊，说，你是一只坏羊，坏羊，因为你的血弄到了我的衣服或我的裙子上。你知道我在说什么吗？
They would take you, maybe torture you, or maybe kill you, or put you under so much stress and circumstances. And then they would say, you are a bad person because you've been through those things. Why did you put me through those things in the first place?
他们会带走你，也许折磨你，也许杀了你，或者让你承受太大的压力和环境。然后他们会说，你是一个坏人，因为你经历了那些事情。为什么你当初要让我经历那些事情呢？
In the years Abdullah was gone, his parents moved to a new house, a big house with lots of rooms. But there was no bedroom for him. His old clothes were gone. They thought he would never come home. He says, it's like he's come back from the dead.
阿卜杜拉离开的几年里，他的父母搬到了新房子，一个有很多房间的大房子。但没有他的卧室。他的旧衣服都没了。他们以为他永远回不了家了。他说，就像他从死里复活了一样。
Jack Hitt, in New Haven.
杰克·希特，在新哈文。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our web site. Production help from Sam Hallgren and Thea Chaloner. And our music help from Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、戴安·库克、简·费尔特斯、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特运营我们的网站。Sam Hallgren和Thea Chaloner提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our web site www.thisamericanlife.org. And you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org。你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know what he always says about us.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由Torey Malatia先生负责。你知道他总是怎么评价我们。
If anybody actually met these guys, actually looked at them, you know, had them on TV shows, they'd be shocked.
如果有人真的见了这些人，真的看了他们，你知道，让他们上电视节目或广播，他们会感到震惊。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories this of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多属于这种美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。